[Music]
the San Francisco fog is clearing making
room for a cloud Google clouds fourth
annual event with thousands of attendees
have travelled from around the world to
learn collaborate and build a cloud for
everyone welcome to next 2019 in San
Francisco
[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining us on the
next live show I'm reto Meier
and I'm Stephanie Wong if you can't be
here in person this week we've got you
covered to make sure you catch
everything we have 6 live stream
channels including this one the next
live show let's kick things off with
insights on this morning's keynote from
Google cloud leaders of Poorna Sinha
group product manager kubernetes and
Quentin Hardy head of editorial great to
see you both
thanks for having us Quentin we were
just here together nine months ago
talking about the state of cloud
computing and that wasn't very long ago
what have you seen that's changed that's
cloud time for you nine months equals a
year and two things stick out one
obviously new leadership we have a new
leader at Google cloud and the first
keynote is very telling he's focused on
customer ready Enterprise ready products
and services and a wealth of them and
customer testimonials backing that up
which is fun to see the other thing is
the products a wealth of products a
year's worth of products in nine months
I'd like to just cite one of them the
cloud services platform which is now
called anthos last summer when it was
launched it was perspective it was going
to be an alpha and then beta very
rapidly it's ready in nine months with
more features and products and services
within it than we could imagine having
done this quickly yay to your team and
what this allows is for you to create
deploy update run check secure all these
applications on prem in google cloud on
all the clouds wherever you want just
take the asset and make it grow and make
it live better in a system that is open
and secure and aimed at customer needs
no opponent you've been closely involved
in the creation of the cloud services
platform or and thoughts now based on
what TK has already shared it already
does a lot right but it's gonna do even
so what will that look like and why
should that matter to our customers yeah
well you know great computing platforms
don't just add features or you know
reduce costs great computing platforms
actually change the game entirely
they give customers capabilities that
they've not had
for and that's what Antho says anthos
you know can be used even if you're not
in the cloud so it can be used in your
on-prem data center to give you a cloud
like environment cloud like agility and
speed but also cloud like control and
centralized risk management and it gives
both your operators and your developers
a level of visibility operational
visibility as well as ease of use for
the developer that is hard to find
anywhere else and then if you do decide
that you're going to use a public cloud
and those gives you what no one else
gives you which is choice and it allows
you to write once and deploy your
services anywhere and that's you know
what really accelerates your business
success the reason we like open systems
yes it's a better way to make more
secure software it's better choice you
get more velocity these are all great
advantages there's an element of
self-interest here too though by leaving
it up to the customer by giving that
freedom and choice it compels us to stay
competitive we have to listen more
closely we have to respond more quickly
and if you have locked in customers it's
kind of a recipe for mediocrity I think
one of the things that a lot of
customers like about the cloud is that
they don't have to worry about all of
the things you know they can focus on
the things that are important to them
and things that add value to their
business so for example developers and
engineers can focus on differentiated
capabilities that are unique and the
cloud takes care of all the rest but why
only in the cloud you know this is
something that you ought to be able to
do on Prem as well and that's what
anthos does it dissolves the layers that
are underneath the differentiating
pieces and those are managed by cloud by
Google cloud or they're managed
automatically and that way you know your
business can focus on accelerating
itself right it seems like it's picking
the workloads that make sense for our
customers Quentin we you mentioned
before we started that modernizing and
migraine was another big keynote
takeaway how does google cloud
integration with and migration of
enterprise systems help
customers exactly when Aparna was just
saying why can't it do more and in this
case why can't your data do more why
can't all that hard work that people
established over decades learning their
customers learning their market learning
their products be taken to the cloud or
be empowered inside on-premise systems
and get new life get new power find new
insights with ml and AI or by employing
other cloud services just refreshing all
that and taking that legacy and using
that as an insight to move into the
future speaking of this focus on our
users Quentin what do you think are some
of the most compelling examples of
learnings that come with working with
our customers you know it's easy to do
in tech deliver a lot of complexity and
come some companies love complexity
because it's kind of like lock-in if you
can get somebody to learn all that
complexity they'll never learn anything
else they'll be afraid you know what's
hard simplicity simplicity on the
backend for the provider is really tough
because you got to consider a lot of use
cases you got to build in a way that's
going to work for a lot of different
interests in people and locations that
requires a lot of careful thought and
you've got to have a kind of empathy for
what the customer wants to do what does
the customer want to do the customer
wants to do the things it's good at the
customer he or she wants to proceed with
the things they've learned in the market
with the products they're passionate
about that might not actually be
container management that's something
work passionate about that's something
we do and in some ways this is economics
101 let everybody focus on their
comparative advantage we are freeing up
customers we are giving them that
simplicity so they can get stuff out of
the way and just work on the problems to
serve their customers opponents been
talking a lot about business folks but
what does this mean for the operators
and the developers are going to be using
this technology yeah well like I said
it's a game changer for the operators
and the developers I would say there are
three kind of big changes number one is
the right ones deploy anywhere for
developers it means that you can focus
on the things that add differentiation
to your business for the CIO it means
actually that you can really concentrate
your talent you don't fragment your
talent across multiple different code
bases around if uhrin types of tools and
if you think about it you know every
customer I've talked to always says the
talent is the most scarce resource
particularly engineering talent is
really hard to hire it's really hard to
you know keep the talent motivated and I
think the reason creators are excited
about anthos is again for the same
reasons right because they also get
access to a multi cloud platform they
also get access to the benefits of
something that's you know at a level
that they can differentiate their code
and don't have to worry about the
underlying you know infrastructure
pieces Quentin Google's CEO sundar
Pichai was an important part of the day
one Kino as well what did his presents
say about how Google sees the cloud
industry well obviously you bring out
the CEO of Google he's putting the stamp
on that this is big and you can't say
that enough and this gets kind of to an
abstract reality of where we are right
now in the world there are four major
players five you could go to six five to
ten billion in capex each this is a very
big stakes operation because this is the
infrastructure of the future as much as
you think about airports or highways or
deepwater ports or telephones and
Telegraph's in their time this is the
infrastructure of the future that we are
building and our competitors they're
building we're building it with a
certain spirit we've talked about today
we think will give the customers the
most power give individuals of any size
a small company large company freelancer
you name it greater energy greater power
greater freedom to realize what they
want to do in the world thank you so
much for joining us again and sharing
your insights great to be thank you
thanks for having us we've only just
begun the first day here at next
nineteen San Francisco and there's still
so much coming your way as we mentioned
earlier we have six live stream channels
build run analyze and learn secure
collaborate and of course the next live
show will have product demos hand-picked
bite-sized breakout sessions for you to
watch which we're calling def bytes as
well as interviews with Google experts
and more visit Chico's slash next on air
to see the full program schedule and
join the Google cloud conversation using
hashtag
next nineteen across our social channels
and be sure to keep the next live show
streaming throughout the day so you
don't miss a thing
coming up on the next live show our
fellow developer advocate Chelsie
Hightower will join us to share with his
thoughts on anthos and Surrealists keep
streaming and we'll see you after this
short break stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show as
promised fellow developer advocate
Kelsey Hightower is here to join us
thanks for being here Kelsey I'm happy
to be here so earlier we heard CK's
keynote what are you most excited about
well given my background in kubernetes
I'm most excited about anthos which is
kind of giving kubernetes to more people
in their environments so you can run it
on prim you can run on Google cloud also
like the addition of Sto so giving
people the ability to manage the
networking playing like they do for
their compute and I think the other
thing I'm most happy about is more
unmanaged databases so now having a
sequel server lots of our customers
asked for a sequel server so pairing
managed databases with something like
kubernetes is kind of a perfect match
right and Google has a really strong
tradition of developer teams passing on
creative software innovations to our
emerging developer audiences
what could you tools can you tell us
about that are also empowering our
enterprise developers with years of
experience in proprietary systems yeah I
think for the biggest thing is like
meeting developers where they are so
kind of integrating with their IDs given
them familiar open-source technology so
a lot of developers are running things
like docker and Cooper neighs on the
laptop envoy packaged in sto so what
we're doing is taking all these open
source projects that you may be using on
your own machines or maybe even
internally and we're just adding a lot
of that support stuff that you would
need to run it in production in the
enterprise so we can see that values are
shifting up the stack with higher level
sets of services and new abstractions
how is automation evolving the developer
experience previously we've been trying
to automate a lot of bad practices right
like if you automate directly on the
virtual machine for example now you're
trying to automate around scripts we had
a lot of configuration management tools
but the api's weren't there now as you
move up the stack things like kubernetes
give us a declarative interface for
deploying on a distribute system so
containers batch drops con jobs so now
we started think about automation you're
finally targeting api's so what we were
able to do for traditional software
development we're now able to do for
infrastructure so bringing things like
sto which gives you a declarative API
for the networking
things like our service add-on give you
a declarative API for your servlet stack
so when you look across the spectrum now
for infrastructure you're now
programming finally towards well-defined
api's so this is sort of supporting
people where they are and i want to talk
about gk on prime and hybrid workloads
what are some of the benefits of it and
what can you what consists admins kind
of weight from that yeah I think since
kubernetes cam out everyone was like I
want it right and gke when you click
that button you just get this magical
cluster production-ready phrase ago and
the next thing is like well what about
my existing environment and many people
have kind of tried to do it and not
everyone has the same level of expertise
or time so the nice thing about this is
that we're going to take gke the same
bits that we use to host on GCP we're
now bringing that into your data center
so we've given people clear guidance on
the lower level requirements and then we
just layered gke on top and then we give
the same API is the same control plains
so if you're using things like terraform
on GCP you're now able to point that
same stack in your arm premium
environment get that same workflow that
you loved so much on GK nice now
kubernetes is being adopted and adapted
to meet more more technical needs and
tell us about how gke hub helps admins
with hybrid environments do their jobs
better yeah so gku hub so once you kind
of get a taste of kubernetes the next
thing is you want Coover naze everywhere
right every problem you see you want to
rub kubernetes on top of it so a lot of
our customers have more than one cluster
if you think about it a lot of our
customers that have value high
availability they'll have a cluster Pro
region or poor zone so once you start to
have a collection of clusters even you
bring an arm prim into the mix you need
a place to a great all of those things
so what gke hub represents is the
ability to aggregate all of your
kubernetes clusters even the ones on
prim and then once you have that you
have a centralized place to do things
like policy management so once you have
a kubernetes cluster the thing you have
to think about is security across all
those clusters and one thing that's kind
of hard or error-prone is you have to
try to figure out how to get your
configuration correct across all of
those clusters so the hub is going to be
the anchor point where we build a lot of
those additional tools that allow you to
manage everything from a central place
nice all right well thanks Kelsey we
really appreciate you taking the time
awesome thank you right now if you have
more questions for Kelsey or a comment
about the gke
on-prem talk reach out to us on social
media using
hashtag Google next 19 and we'll try to
answer some of your questions during the
show and of course we'll see Kelsey back
here in about an hour to talk several
solutions for developers but right now
let's talk about perks when you watch
the next live show you'll get exclusive
access to some sessions only available
to livestream viewers that we're calling
dev bytes so grab a notebook and enjoy
the first deaf-blind on anthos
originally known as CSP find out how you
can leverage gke on prem and the anthos
product suite to manage a true vibrant
environment hi my name is Weston
Hutchins and I'm a product manager for
gke on Prem even with more and more
workloads moving to the public cloud
on-premise software remains a necessity
for many enterprise organizations every
Enterprise has apps that are difficult
to move to the cloud or restrictions on
where sensitive workloads can run many
are looking for a true hybrid story one
where they can modernize the apps for
the cloud but continue running in their
own data center many companies have
looked to kubernetes to give them a
consistent environment between on
przemek cloud but getting started with
kubernetes is challenging there are over
50 distributions and choosing the right
tools to install kubernetes can prove
daunting and then once you get a cluster
up and running you enter the land of day
to operations where you not only need to
lean but considerable operational
expertise to manage the lifecycle of a
kubernetes cluster we find a lot of
customers that start down the route of
building their own in-house DIY tooling
to manage kubernetes later struggled to
keep that tooling up to date Google's
answer for hybrid is cloud services
platform a stack that takes the best of
cloud native open technologies like
kubernetes and sto and lets you run them
in your data center but the key benefit
of CSP is the collection of cloud
services that integrate your on-prem in
cloud workloads into a single unified
experience services like binary
authorization for security unified
logging and monitoring through
stackdriver or centralized policy
management that syncs access controls
across all of your clusters at next 19
will deep dive into the infrastructure
layer for CSP GK on Prem
GK and Ram takes all of the tech
nology behind gke and installs it on top
of vmware in your data center once
installed you register your cluster with
Google's cloud console to give your
administrators and developers a single
pane of glass for managing their
clusters and apps and I talking next
well take a detailed look into a
real-world use case Arctic one of our
CSP solution providers recently rolled
out GaN Prem to one of their customers
Activa a telecommunications services
company will walk throughout tvs
architecture show how GK and Prem
integrated with their existing tools and
workflows and gives them tips for your
own installation of GK on prime check
out the breakout session online and
we'll get you up and running with GK on
Prem in no time okay stick around the
next session will begin shortly remember
to check out the five other channels for
curated content on build run analyze and
learn secure and collaborate and after
the session Kelsi Hightower returns to
talk about several solutions for our
developers see you back here in an hour
[Music]
we couldn't get enough of him so we
brought him back joining us once more is
Kelsey Hightower developer advocate at
Google cloud Kelsey talk to us about how
civil solutions help developers yes I
think several the solutions for people
new to server lists it's kind of like
we've learned a lot of patterns from
four or five years of kubernetes and all
the things you need to do to provide
that higher-level interface that you
give all your developers or that you
enjoy working with every day that's
where service attempts to start so we
take some of those patterns and we give
people the smallest interface that they
want to do so if you think about it if a
file gets uploaded to a Google cloud
storage bucket you can just invoke your
business logic and execute your code for
you now people wants to relist but they
also want containers how is Google
enabling developers to have both the
velocity of serverless
and the flexibility of containers that's
the thing that I'm probably the most
proud of so when several this is most
introduced for first introduced and most
people they always thought about as
functions as a service you write a
single function and event comes in it
calls your function but there's a lot of
existing business logic that needs a
little bit more than just a single
function we've there's some
bootstrapping code you gotta set up
things like logging but a little bit
more flexibility and your choice of
runtime so what we decided to do was
take a lot of the learnings from
kubernetes and allow developers to
deploy their own docker containers so
any runtime that you want to use any
business logic that you want any
libraries and we're going to execute
that container just like we do with our
cloud functions so they scale to zero
they scale up quick and they give you
the same service workflow that you used
to without abandoning all the good
things that come with containers yes
you've talked a little bit about you
know service isn't brand new but we're
changing the way that we're sort of
approaching it can you can you tell us a
little bit more about how Google is
changing that service experience so I
think for us is that our DNA has always
been around this idea of this kind of
software delivery chain right so this
idea that when you build a software we
like to build it once we sign those
images
and then we decide where we want them to
be deployed so that means giving people
a bit of choice
so typically service has been kind of
these proprietary cloud platforms once
you're in there you're kind of locked in
what we decided to do is make sure that
it runs everywhere so wherever you as a
developer want to run just like most
Google tools and libraries we allow our
servlet stack to run wherever you are so
I think what we're doing different here
is taking some of the things that worked
well in the kubernetes space and combine
them with some of the developer
experiences that we know that people are
looking for and just combining the two
so flexibility without the without
losing the trade-offs and benefits of
going server list that's great so how
does server list our service offering
help our developers and how is it
different I think where it's different
is that you get to use a familiar tour
chain that has been popularized over the
last couple of years right so containers
are the way most people think about
having full control over their own
software then to be able to take that
software and outsource all of the
delivery right so security I am
integration being able to connect to
things like spanner and bigquery taking
all of that kind of toil away from you
and just say hey check in your
containers and we'll run them for you so
what we're trying to do is kind of make
it very seamless from a developer once
you go from idea to deployed we're just
trying to give you that same with DCP
experience at the container level nice
now how do I service offering is give
developers a more open and portable
offering so that customers can
potentially move their workloads around
so one thing the trend that has been
really prevalent in GCP is in kubernetes
we started with docker popular open
source container runtime and then we
shipped an open source project
kubernetes which is the underlying
platform for gke and then when we
thought about entering servlet so we've
had App Engine for it for almost 11
years now and we decided that let's what
would we do we wanted to make App Engine
be more open so we decided to start with
the K native project so K native has a
lot of service component you can think
of as a service toolkit things like
builds a function framework and most of
that stuff is laid on top of kubernetes
so what we've done is we took in the
best parts of kubernetes again those
design patterns that we talked about how
do I just run my application we've
restricted that out into a high level
set of libraries called K native and
there's a hosted version we call cloud
run and we also give you the ability to
run cloud run on top of gke
so the benefit there is that if you need
to do some machine learning you can take
that serverless workload and run on a
specialized VM with a GPU or TPU so
you're no longer restricted to our just
our service runtime environments you now
have the whole of GCP opened up to you
even in the service context you touched
on this a bit but a lot of our customers
tell us that they have customer
requirements like specific runtimes
custom binaries or workload portability
and more often than not they turn to
containers for an answer can you talk
about how our gke serverless add-on
allows you to bring serverless to
containers yes when you think about a
lot of these abstractions change over
time we went from mainframe to physical
machines to virtualization to
higher-level platforms like App Engine
what we now have with the container
image this ability to build a code that
you want use the runtime that you want
any version that you want and now that
becomes a portable bit you can run this
on a virtual machine you can run this on
gke you can run this on cloud run and
you can also run it on App Engine so I
think what a developer gets is this
ability to truly write once and deploy
wherever they want now
well we believe Google Cloud is a great
place to run old types of workloads some
customers we know that they need to run
on-premises or across multiple clouds
right so tell us about a little bit more
about Kay native and its role in giving
developers the freedom to move stateless
containers pretty much anywhere yeah so
our contribution to the ecosystem
started with maybe kubernetes right soku
Bernays over the four or five years you
can see it now it's deployed and offered
by every major cloud provider lots of
people are already running it on Prem so
it has a wide adoption so our strategy
of layering Kay native on top of
kubernetes this allows us to kind of
reap those benefits so the tools that
you're familiar with we lay our k native
on top so that gives us that portability
framework underneath so no matter where
you're running whether it's on Prem
different cloud provider on GCP you can
get the same API is right so we talked
earlier about automating those api's
that's what kubernetes represents and
I've always set the discriminators as a
platform for building platforms and
we've chosen to build our newest service
platforms on top of kubernetes can you
talk a little bit more about how Canada
provides eventing and integrating events
from Google or third-party services so
you can
really extend your applications so the
big thing to know about K native is not
just Google's project right so now we
have so many contributors
you know Red Hat Cloud Foundry so a lot
of the things that we've seen in the
eventing space like what is an event how
should we accept it I'll have those open
protocols like cloud events all of that
supported inside key native so kata nato
gives you a couple of components we call
key native serving run my container
scale it 2-0 started again when a
request comes in then you have the event
team piece so there's an event and what
we wanted to do is make event portable
so different cloud providers has a
different collection of events different
transports for events so we wanted to do
is make sure that the event framework
was very flexible if you want to
integrate with github or GCP or one of
some other service that you have that
you defined yourself that's also
included so what we've done is we given
all of these framework pieces and what
we've done with cloud run is we've kind
of curated the perfect snack for you
great and is there a particular way in
which we were able to solve that problem
that you described of like having all of
these things leaving all of these
different places yes I think for us is
kubernetes is super flexible so what
that flexibility allows every cloud
provider to do their own integration for
example arm Prem we come out of the gate
integrating with things like with VMware
and f5 so we abstract away some of the
differences between all of these
platforms so that's what kubernetes is
job is once you have that set of
abstractions things like Kay native just
sit on top and naively assume that those
abstractions are there and then we can
get on with building those higher-level
platforms so Cooper days is a huge part
of this and the community has been doing
this work for over four years abstract
in the way the differences between these
cloud providers so whenever you build on
top of that we just inherit all of those
benefits well thank you so much again
for joining us today Kelsey awesome
thanks for having me if you want to
rewatch or share our conversation with
Kelsey on serverless solutions for
developers visit gqo slash next on-air
now we turn our attention to the next
dev byte
here's a detailed technical look at
networking design techniques for running
applications at scale check this out
like many developers interested in micro
services you start off dabbling with
google kubernetes engine our powerful
cluster manager and orchestration system
for a new docker con
first you accept all the defaults and
then slowly start modifying a few
parameters to support your application
as you spend more time your confidence
increases more traffic and
mission-critical applications move to GK
which is great you will be able to
benefit from GK ease advanced cluster
management features soon enough your
cluster size gradually starts increasing
things seems to be going fine until one
day when you start hitting scalability
and manageability issues that can often
be avoided by implementing some key best
practices during cluster creation over
the next few sections we'll be covering
some of the best practices features and
designs in GK networking that can help
you scale and manage your GK footprint
as your business grows first let's talk
about VPC native clusters as you know
kubernetes mandates direct pod to pod
connectivity but there is more than one
way to achieve this by default
kubernetes uses static routes for pod
networking which requires the kubernetes
control plane to maintain these routes
to each node this comes at a scaling
cost in gke we give you the option to
create clusters and VPC native mode
which provides container native
networking BBC native node is enabled
with a single click and enables
connectivity between all the pause in
your V PC without the overhead of route
scaling the V PC control panel
automatically manages routing setup for
pods and the native integration of
container networking in the V PC fabric
improves scalability and integration
between kubernetes and other V PC
features kubernetes also makes very
liberal use of IP addresses which
simplifies the system and makes it
easier to use and comprehend but on the
flip side
this makes IP management a challenge for
kubernetes deployment this is
exacerbated in a hybrid deployment or
where IPs are fragmented making IPs a
scarce resource VPC native sources by
providing flexibility in defining your
cluster scale requirements upfront for
resources like pods nodes and services
so instead of having hundred resources
and thousands of IPs
you can now have 100 resources 128
eyepiece this allows for kubernetes to
reduce his IP for
prynt thereby improving the overall IP
utilization VPC native clusters also
enable other enterprise-grade features
for example sharing VP C's between
projects I am and role separation
providing anti-spoofing security in our
Sdn stack and also private clusters for
cluster isolation
apart from scaling security is another
criteria that needs to be considered in
best practice enterprise users require a
deployment in which your services and
networks are isolated and accessible
only within trusted boundaries gke
provides through private clusters
private clusters makes the worker node
and the cluster max master accessible
only within the trusted boundaries any
unauthorized access to a control plane
is set to default deny for a road board
you use case in enterprise private
cluster also provides a wall garden
access to control plane through private
endpoints which is provisioned by the
customer another best practice to be
aware of for applications at scale is
how you expose your services to the
Internet when you need to deploy your
applications you may start off using a
cluster based ingress controller such as
engine X or H a proxy this is really
familiar for a lot of us it's just a
standard proxy that you would run on
your laptop you would then expose your
application to the Internet using a
layer 4 kubernetes service load balancer
however when your application scales up
you will want to use the Google ingress
implementation in gke the gke container
native ingress is a globally scalable
low latency distributed proxy layer that
supports many of the built-in features
such as caching authentication and DDoS
protection you won't want to fiddle with
how many instances of your proxies to
scale up too or worry about how to
absorb an attack in addition the Google
ingress has built-in support for
container native load balancing using
Network and point groups this means that
the network traffic will be balanced
directly to the container in your V PC
skipping the overhead of bouncing
through the Kuban it is Q proxy layer
you'll also be able to easily debug your
traffic as your connections no longer
need address translation to get to their
destination there are also other subtle
advantages you advantages of using
Google ingress
instead of cluster based controllers
such as connection imbalance and
accurate end-to-end health checks for
your packets gke makes the job of
deploying a scalable kubernetes much
less daunting and offers many features
that allow you to future-proof your
deployment we have only scratched the
surface here and there are many other
techniques that helps in scalability and
manageability of your cluster please
attend the hy beat three one four
session at next twenty nineteen SF to
learn more about these tools and tips
[Music]
remember you can re-watch that dev byte
or the session in its entirety scalable
and manageable deep dive into gke
on demand at jidoka slash next on-air
but let's switch gears now and talk
about PayPal most of us know that PayPal
provides a global online payment system
but what you might not know is how
Google clouds artificial intelligence
the machine learning gives PayPal the
ability to provide enhanced customized
experience to their customers and
merchants even faster take a look today
we're seeing transformation all around
the world data is exploding consumer
expectations are changing as there's
growth in online commerce there is a
huge need to support that unless
actually you change how you think you'll
not be able to go through this
transformation public cloud technologies
are no longer and if it's definitely a
matter of when we pick Google cloud and
that's made a huge difference
developers must be artists they should
focus on painting great experiences for
the customers with Google Cloud you now
have systems that are more reliable up
all the time
secure and economically viable that
means better productivity for our
engineers we have improved the velocity
for my developers say I want 100 VMs now
and in two minutes those VMs are set up
they are impacting my end customers or
consumers and merchants because now they
are getting the features faster then
that's huge we had to get very better at
leveraging our data the expertise that
Google had in machine learning and
artificial intelligence was a key factor
and now we can go down to each
individual merchant and each individual
consumer and give them a catered
experience PayPal is not just a payments
utility we are a company with a larger
purpose for Humanity helping people who
did not have access to services that you
and I take for granted that's that's
what we are trying to do with payments
Google cloud is going to allow us to
take our business to the next level
and that is really exciting
it's time for us to step away after the
next session you'll want to meet us back
here if you're considering hybrid cloud
for your work hen Goldberg Google anthos
gke engineering director will join us
for a deep dive on a skill that is
critical to any business that demands
developer velocity and quality from GCP
stick around you're watching the next
live show from San Francisco
[Music]
hi there and thanks for joining us I'm
Aaron Meyer many of us are reaching for
hybrid cloud nirvana which makes the
workplace mobility between on-premise
and cloud computing ideal for our work
to help us navigate through this we
welcome hen goldberg engineering
director for google cloud nice to have
you here hi thank you very much for
inviting me
absolutely now hybrid cloud is a common
strategy that businesses look to
modernize while still supporting their
current applications how does Google
cloud approach this particular challenge
so first of all it's important to
understand why customers one or more
than ice and what they are looking for
that and the most important thing is for
them to in order to compete they have to
increase their developer agility and
have them to be more focused and they
really want to take advantage of the
amazing capabilities that are available
in the cloud and using new cloud
services but they have to make a
decision and it choice because they
cannot modernize everything at once
that's one of the concern the second
thing is that they also have concerns
from regulations that require them to
stay on premises so from their
perspective it is a reality that hybrid
is here to say and they have to choose a
hybrid strategy in order to modernize
and advance their business for us in
Google cloud we understand that way to
support our customers in their journey
ok and our goal is to make sure that we
help them reduce the risk instead of
increasing the risk when going through
this journey and restart coming in
different different levels for example
and not fragmenting your talent and
lying to create a consistent experience
everywhere and also really leveraging
the existing assets you have today so
not asking them to buy a new soft a new
hard well for example but really
blending in to their existing
environment and how does this truly
differ from other hybrid offerings
Google puts the user at first in the
center and we understand that our
customers appreciate to have choice ok
they want to be able to choose where
they're going to deploy their workloads
what kind of tools to use which services
to use and our goal is to make that
possible while reducing risk we do it we
do it by building our platform based on
open source technology
which are ensuring that their walkers
are portable and we are not locking them
in and we are also now approaching
multi-cloud strategically and giving
consistent experience wherever customers
choose to deploy the workloads now
that's amazing what components make up
anthos and how do those components work
together to provide a really integrated
approach for our customers so others is
a opinion platform managed by Google in
the foundation in the core of it we are
using open source technologies
originated by Google like kubernetes
sto and key native but this is not
sufficient for a customer to manage
their trigenics environments they have
on top of that we are building a multi
cloud multi cluster control plane that
lets our customers connect to all of
their environments and manage them in a
consistent through a single pane of
glass we also give them tools to manage
policies and control in all of those
environments but not everything is
containerized and this is also about
investing with what they have today so
on top of that we are creating a service
management platform which allows them to
connect all those services because of
what the compute there is and on top of
everything we have an awesome
marketplace that allows us to provide
both first polity and third party
applications available in all of those
environments so you just mentioned
investing and what our customers are
already using today how can aunt those
be used to help them modernize in place
so what we hear from our customers that
when they come and they want to use new
cloud services they have first to
qualify and make sure that the cloud
meets their bow but let's say they want
to use bigquery or even gke they need to
go through the specific process usually
manual process to make sure they can let
their developers use it with G key on
Prem they don't need to go through that
process because we bring this technology
into their Dana Center and they know it
meets the ball so that's actually the
fastest way for them to innovate that's
great what about config management with
anthos how can you write multi cluster
policies right out of the box so that's
a great question I think that the number
one concern that
have is how they manage risk and
specifically how can they make sure that
they know who access what resources and
making sure that they know what policies
are applied everywhere and when you have
more and more environments you have to
build more and more tools and have more
people manage that so Antos config
management allows you to manage those
policies from a centralized place and
even if by accident or by a malicious
user someone is trying to break that
policy automatically we will apply that
policy and bring that environment and it
back to be compliant so more
environments more tools can you
elaborate on what we're doing to give
users the visibility they need so that
they can see what's happening across all
these environments yes so we are
leveraging open api's which allows us to
actually integrate with every
environment wherever the user chooses
and we are creating tools centralized
tools in the control plane that gives
you signals or monitoring data from all
of those environments in a consistent
way and we're also leveraging things
like key native we just announced cloud
rounds beta to give a simple and
effective user experience for developers
again to deploy to all of those
environments so when I think about it
it's not about portability of workloads
but it's actually about portability of
skills can my developers can my service
operators use the same set of tools
regardless of which environment they
want to use and by leveraging open
source technologies this is actually
possible it's fantastic I'm curious you
know they're our customers using anthos
today and what are some of the more
interesting use cases that you may have
come across I'm smiling because ever
since we've announced back then it was
CSP eight months ago it's alpha we've
seen an overwhelming excitement with our
customers over 1,000 customers showed
interest just during next to tryout CSP
anthos and we see different type of use
cases
so I would say for someone like HSBC
they were excited to give their
developers platform on modern platform
without having to go through all the
qualification making sure that the new
environment means about so they are
doing both but they know that for some
of the workload they will have to stay
on Prem it will see other customers like
Cole's for example that are looking to
innovate both on Prem and in the cloud
and create a consistent environment and
maybe talking about a customer like key
bank ok so they are really excited about
the agility so really leveraging new
tools and making that they can deploy
quickly in other environments so
different customers see different use
cases to begin with but they are all
very excited by both agility and
reducing risk thanks man for walking us
through the possibilities of anthos
thank you for having me of course now if
you want to re-watch or share Ken's
interview or any other content you've
seen on the next live show check out
jidoka slash next on-air and if you've
got a question or comment reach out to
us on social media using the hashtag
Google next nineteen we have another
first look for you on the next live show
this next dev fight is all about the
tools developers should know how to use
in order to drive productivity take a
look GCB is a set of solutions and
products that can help you solve your
toughest business challenges we have
external paying customers that run
businesses on our platforms and at
massive scale these customers expect
developer velocity and quality we have
thousands of engineers at Google
building this platform at all levels of
the stack these engineers want a
seamless developer workflow
deterministic signals insights and
velocity it is GCP engineering
productivity teams role to balance these
two dimensions between developer
velocity and quality for example we
deploy GCP is console twice a week to
our users
and with high quality our goal is to
establish bi-weekly high quality
releases across GCB at Google we have
created a set of guiding principles that
let us have both developer velocity and
quality we want to share these
principles and the tools that are
available to you so you can accelerate
at the pace your users expect why we at
Google initially focused on test
engineering over a decade ago we started
looking at engineering productivity
holistically this gave us the framework
to achieve the right balance between
developer velocity and quality this
meant that in addition to doing complex
qualification across systems we started
focusing on tooling and infrastructure
that enabled developers themselves to
qualify their code changes before they
commit them this in turn allows us not
only to catch bugs but prevent them too
this changed the way we built qualified
and deployed our applications and we
started pushing the boundaries of both
developer velocity and quality be
balanced developer velocity and quality
at Google and on GCP through project
health ph we track key metrics across
developer productivity release velocity
reliability and most importantly quality
we automatically calculate a pH level
and aim to achieve a pH level of 5 for
all projects our guiding principles are
driving test health avoiding performance
regressions and high quality automated
releases all of which are anchored in
actionable metrics
let's zoom in on two of these driving
tests health and avoiding performance
regressions for driving test health we
aim for hermetic integration tests for
specimens and elimination of tests
flakiness we have built a cloud
integration testing framework internally
that helps us write tests once and run
them against any environment we enable
developers to catch performance issues
early in the development process to
avoid performance regressions we are a
framework that enables developers to
create sustainable performance
automation that can gate releases on
performance criteria and we aim to
improve GC peace quality and deployment
by reducing manual toil increasing
automation eliminating cherry-picks and
improving the fidelity of the test
signal in our pre-production
environments let's dive deeper into what
we are doing for the external developer
and user Google works closely with the
external kubernetes and hto developer
communities to enable developer
productivity in open source kubernetes
is an open source system for automating
deployment scaling and management of
containerized applications while sto is
an open source service mesh that
provides traffic management policy
enforcement and telemetry collection we
are active contributors to special
interest group SEC testing in kubernetes
some of the tooling we helped build in
the open source community includes prowl
the continuous integration CI system
used by kubernetes and a lot of other
projects that use kubernetes prowl is
built on top of kubernetes so our CI
helps test kubernetes on kubernetes
des grid provides a grid of the
seasons making it easy to see patterns
over time provides fast access and
allows interactive sorting filtering
grouping and more it is highly
configurable and integrated the cloud
belt recently we helped build hermetic
testing using kubernetes in darker kind
brings up a conformant kubernetes
cluster locally without any external
dependencies for testing kubernetes
changes or integration testing
kubernetes applications kubernetes was
designed with Portability and
interoperability in mind and providers
want to enable application portability
Google alongside other cloud providers
helps out with the cloud native
computing foundations conformance
program which ensures certified
kubernetes products deliver consistency
and portability the outside world now
uses VMs kubernetes containers scalable
storage github and so on Google software
is stored in a single shared repository
the development landscape is rapidly
changing and we are evolving our tooling
and incorporating external tooling to
adapt to this changing landscape
summarizing we believe that if you
prioritize driving test health treat
performance in the first-class citizen
and have automated CI CD that enables
high quality releases and measure
everything you can have the same
developer velocity and quality as we do
[Music]
thanks team if you want to share this
dev fight or watch the complete session
check out move fast and don't break
things on Chico slash next on-air at
Google cloud our customer stories are
truly inspiring to hear we take you to
Indonesia now to profile go check a
company that uses Google cloud to not
only scale quickly but to bring the
marketplace and millions of Indonesians
closer together
innovation Jakarta the level of traffic
is so bad that it is a real quality of
life issue a lack of access has
prevented groups of people groups of
businesses from really achieving their
true potential we started on the
realization that the object driver could
do so much more and we expanded our
services based on what we thought would
be beneficial for the lives of millions
of indonesia's which created these very
reasons for solving people's real
problems in a very very practical manner
and that's where I think the craziness
has started we scaled 900 times in the
first 18 months we are doing over 3
million orders a day there are over
150,000 merchants on a platform like we
do every 15 seconds we're getting a ping
from our driver app that tells us where
they are what their status is we're
signaling heat maps that come from our
above data flows so that drivers know
where they are most needed it's about
helping drivers
make better decisions for themselves a
logo Technica fetches kita and Bucca
shadow duel Antigua
previously were mostly concerned around
how to put food on the table are now
concerned about how they can afford
their child's college education all of
that is very inspiring to see how the
lives of millions of people are changing
[Music]
it's really inspiring to see how go Jack
has created opportunities for people
across all of Indonesia all right now
it's time for the next group of sessions
to start once they're finished join us
back here to learn how to develop for
kubernetes without leaving your IDE
you're watching the next live show from
San Francisco hi I'm Stephanie Wong
welcome back to the next live show it's
only day one of next and we've covered a
ton of ground already we started the day
with the opening keynote followed by
post keynote chats with Google leaders
and product demos if you missed any of
it visit gqo slash next on eric's watch
it all on demand now let's throw it over
to Mark who has more information on our
boot camps and certification testing
taking place right here at necks 19
[Music]
hey I'm mark and I'm here at the boot
camp section of Google cloud NEX where
we've got thousands of technical
practitioners and developers here to
learn a new skill or get Google cloud
certified attendees can check out
trainings take hands-on labs or get
assessed for Google cloud certification
of course each lifelong learning journey
is a unique one so let's talk to some of
the folks who have been Google cloud
certified I chose to get a Google
certified crime winner to have a very
good knowledge on Google cloud also to
have that confidence especially when you
interact with clients or even within a
company when you want to build a system
to have that confidence
I choose Google cloud certification to
get gained the trust of my clients that
I had the technical skills to build the
best data pipelines and the
architectures for their business
requirements so it shows to be certified
because there is a real a real value for
the certification on the market every
company is really looking for that and
if you want to work in the cloud you
have to have certifications part of it
was knowing that the Google cloud
platform has been growing exponentially
I thought this was the best time to be
well aligned with such an environment in
technology and get that certification
from Google Cloud but the certification
process doesn't stop there they're
taking their teachings back with them to
help their own teams start on their
learning journeys from the certification
right I wanted to gain more and more
learning from my fellow Google cloud
certified team and Googlers or to learn
more real world use cases so part of it
has been career growth on my side
there's been a huge spike from the
clients that have been reaching out to
me and I've also worked with the team of
about four of my team members and would
all dedicate a lot of time to studying
and learning the whole Google Cloud
suite of products that they have to make
that we're perfect for the certification
hopefully this inspires you to start
your own learning journey down Google
cloud certification and seeing what you
can build thanks mark for more
information on becoming google cloud
certified be sure to visit cloud giggle
com certification joining me now is
Priyanka Vergara a customer engineer at
Google cloud who's going to show us how
to develop for kubernetes without
leaving your IDE thanks for being here
thank you for having me I'm gonna talk
about communities and how developers can
work within the original studio
environment and deploy applications into
kubernetes so let's jump right in great
cool so I have on the left hand side my
terminals which we're gonna use to do
some deployments and then on the right
here I have Visual Studio code so we're
going to start off by creating a new
application let's just create a hello
world nodejs application nothing fancy
so what's happening here is we should be
able to see our application create it
once i refresh it is showing up my
application I have the source files the
front-end and the backend
are the different services that are in
this application in the front end we
have the 8080 port that's listening to
the front end it's talking to the back
end on back-end service address and in
the backend we have the index file
that's also talking to 8080 so we're
gonna change that to 80 81 so that we
can we don't have a port conflict and
then at this point if we go into go and
start these services I'm going to just
check where we are in our terminal we're
at the right place in the front-end
folder and we want to do the same for
our back-end as well so I'm going to go
into the right folder which is the
HelloWorld node.js application - and
then so we're now in backends and front
front-end folders now if we run npm
install' that's gonna get us all the
dependencies that it needs to to run the
run both our front-end and back-end
services and then once that is done we
need to stir these service
so our back-end is running on a DAT one
and a front-ends running on a DAT so
we're ready to test our application our
back in is only 81 and our front end is
on 8080 talking to our back-end so we
have an application that's running
through Visual Studio code now at this
point if I wanted to deploy this
application into into gke I would first
need a cluster to create and then once
the prospect roster is created then I
can start deploying this application so
let's see how we how we can create a
cluster from within Visual Studio code I
have the extension for for Visual Studio
code called code gke extension and once
you download that extension you'll start
to see your projects and your custer's
in the in your ID environment I'm going
to just use my current one of the
current projects and create create a
cluster in the current project so my
current project is KQ demo and so we'll
set that as a project ID and then it
gives me an option to select the zones
and then here we're just gonna say test
as a cluster name and then there's the
number of nodes that you want to create
that you can change and then also the
machine types we're just gonna go with
the standard and click create once I do
that it takes a maybe three or four
minutes to actually create the cluster
it's spinning up all these instances in
Google Cloud for you and if i refresh
this you should be able to see that it's
starting to bring up the test cluster
right here it's orange because it's not
set up yet so give it a few minutes and
it starts to set up at this point we're
gonna just use for the demo purpose the
cluster that I already have created and
we'll go through the demo using that
cluster now once I have the cluster I'm
ready to deploy and I need a scaffold
yamo to actually deploy in the cluster
okay and for those who might not have
heard of scaffold what what is that
so scaffold is basically a command line
tool that lets you
define your kubernetes manifest it also
defines the container registries and
then for the back end and the front end
and spur especially for our application
here so if you have a large number of
services that are running in your
application you would define your
container registry addresses in there
and would pick up from from those from
those addresses and deploy your service
in GK right yeah so let's see an example
of that so I'm just first going to go
through deployment I think I forgot to
set the cluster so let's first set this
cluster once it is set then we're going
to deploy take the deploy and do that
starting to deploy while it's deploying
let's look at our scaffold yamo this is
the am Allah is talking about where you
have the backend and the front-end and
the GCR dot io addresses which is the
container registry address and then the
manifest for your kubernetes and it
seems like we have our application
deployed so let's see the IP address
that's the IP address of our application
and it's the one that we just created
and we see that the application is
working on port 4000 so our front end is
talking to our back-end both of them now
deployed on a gke
cluster so we did all of that from our
IDE and yeah that's fantastic I guess
the next step that I would think of is
making changes to let's say our back-end
without affecting our front-end so for
example what if I want to test to make
sure that my change doesn't break
anything without needing to redeploy
redeploy and rebuild that's a great
point because is it in a development
lifecycle that's the biggest you know
hurdle you test you to you develop you
test and then you want to deploy that
but but the test stage is a very
critical stage so you would use
something called telepresence for that
and telepresence is again a command-line
tool that helps you create a proxy so in
this case in this example what we're
going to do is create a proxy and create
our and run our back
and on local machine and then our front
end would continue to run on our gk
cluster in production so we're able to
test the changes to our back end but our
front end stays intact okay so let's see
that yeah so in this case here so when
you come out of this and let's see where
we are I want to go into the application
that we just deployed which is this and
let's make a little bit of a change here
in our front and application so that we
can use a little bit of a so but the I
just called it version two for our back
end and at this point if I run my
telepresence command which is nothing
but it creates a proxy and it's going to
run it on port so here it is it's
forwarding the ports now and if we go
test our back-end and on a local machine
that's going to version two and it
should work the same way from our front
end as well so that's that's pretty much
how it works very impressive so we were
not only able to see you being able to
redeploy using your local IDE to gke
using cloud code and scaffold but you
were also able to make changes locally
to a single service test it and then
again redeploy to gke ones pretty
powerful yeah telepresence okay well
thank you so much again for joining us
thank you for having me let's send it
over to Rado thank you very much
Priyanka and Stefanie stick with us
we're gonna take you to the showcase
floor well we'll see about living a life
of code you're watching the next live
show we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show I'm
reto Meier and I'm Stephanie Wong
we'll be here for all three days of the
conference sharing the Google cloud next
experience with you wherever you are if
you miss anything or want to rewatch and
share a video you like head to gqo slash
next on-air while you're there check out
our other five channels organized by
theme build run analyze and learn secure
and cloud range now let's head over to
the showcase floor where our reporter
Natalie is checking out the cloud run
demo hi everyone wakey at the life of
your code demo and I'm joined here by
Grisha how are you good how are you good
thank you tell us a little bit about
what you do and what you've made awesome
so I am I leave product marketing here
in Google cloud for our service products
and we recently announced a product
called cloud run today and I'm really
excited about that all right can you
show us what it does super so I'm just
going to build a simple app and we're
gonna get started here so what we're
doing right now is think of the Train as
the app itself so we are going to start
by sort of customizing it first and
building our train so building the app
so adding a different different
components like compute database and so
on to the train building the Train
so it's checking for security
vulnerabilities and all of those in the
second step and then finally we're going
to deploy it and we will be able to see
it in the big screen awesome let's get
started
super so getting started here adding a
train car first so the first thing that
we're going to add is the engine itself
so engine here is the compute platform
so let's start with the compute so cloud
run is amazing because it enables the
developer to choose to write apps in any
language they choose so for example with
no js' or c-sharp Python other options
we have here but really any language
they can choose to write their apps on
and it's totally fine so I'm just going
to select a blue color here and then
getting started so now that's our engine
so we're going to add a second train car
here so now what we are doing is so this
is a passenger carriage
what it's doing is it's letting us
select our language in terms of adding a
docker file to the app itself so for as
a developer if I if I'm a Java developer
for example and the cloud vendor doesn't
support Java that's totally fine I can
specify the docker file and it's going
to package my app into the into a
container and it's going to deploy it so
that's what we're seeing here so I'm
gonna select go let's do this colorful
yeah yeah like a dot and so finally now
what we're going to do is add a database
to it so this is a database that I'm
going to add because databases are an
essential component of building enough
so there are different options that you
can add if you want to integrate it with
cloud run so we have a few options here
like MongoDB or Redis or post press
really it works with any of our Google
cloud offerings as well and so you can a
lot of options to choose from so let's
select one of these a green color let's
go ahead alright so we've completed the
build yeah so now what we have here is
this is the app so think of it as a
developer writing code for the entire
app and they're ready to go as a
developer this is all you will have to
do right which is called to what they're
doing they don't have to worry about you
know the infrastructure scaling it up
and down monitoring it managing it all
of that has gone away let's focus on the
code just the code just focus on the
code so now I'm gonna complete the build
so now what it's doing is its pushing
the code to cloud run so it's checking
for security vulnerabilities it's making
sure the the build image the container
image is being created so now you can
see the scale the scanning the security
scanning for the code as well using
cloud build and now all of this is
complete we're going to give it a name
that's your initials G yes great tada
yeah so now we're going to just deploy
it this is the exciting part so the
train is actually going to be seen on
the large screen in just about a second
now awesome oh there it goes that's that
fun so now what it's doing is it's going
through the train station of the QPS
there where it's getting a ton of
traffic so think of your app as a lot of
users using your app so it's getting a
lot of traffic and cloud run will
automatically scale your app from zero
literally if there's no traffic to
whatever instance it needs and then
bring it back down to zero all in just
within seconds wow that was a really
great demonstration thank you so much
for joining us thank you for having me
and back to you the last sessions of the
day are coming up be sure to tune back
in to the next live show tomorrow
morning at 8:55 a.m. we kick off day 2
with the product innovation keynote
followed by an exclusive interview with
Google club's director of AI strategy
Tracy free and remember check out our
library of content from next 19 at
jidoka slash next on it stay tuned for
the last sessions of the day have a
great evening and radar oh and I will
see you back on the next live show
tomorrow
[Music]